Trump keeps insisting that there's
nothing criminal related to what he did
these 37 felony accounts he says it's
all governed by the presidential records
act it is not it doesn't even seem he
knows what that means but it is not
governed by the presidential records act
we are talking here about his actions as
a former president we are talking about
his refusal to give the documents back
when asked we were talking about his
direction of lawyers and others to lie
in obfuscate and hide and refuse to give
back we're talking about all of those
different things
and he keeps insisting it's merely an
issue of the presidential records act
it's not he doesn't get it at this point
it's time to just admit he doesn't get
it he keeps talking about the Clinton
sock drawer tapes as if there's any
equivalency there Bill Clinton recorded
his thoughts while he was in office on
audio tapes he was granted permission to
keep them after a review to use them in
order to I don't remember if it was to
write a book or what it was it's not an
even remotely similar situation